thank you thank you Stefan so what we're
really gonna focus on here today are the
issues they're gonna be most relevant to
you graduating in from Stanford and also
starting up a startup company in a
Silicon Valley and type of issues that
you're gonna face and you'll find that
the issues that you face is an
entrepreneur starting a small company
are much different than you're gonna
face joining a big company so if you're
if you find a job with Google you're
probably not gonna have very many
immigration issues they have a very good
staff there and and the Immigration
Service it really isn't looking to
Google to you know to scrutinize those
cases very much but is it as an
entrepreneur unfortunately can often be
very difficult in your situation
someone who's graduating and F one's
status to to secure work authorization
after your one year of opt so that's
that's sort of the focus but we're also
going to sort of just talk about some of
the immigration basics so you have an
idea some of you might already know this
but but just some of the the language
that you need
no to understand how this process works
so we'll talk about that and we'll talk
about initial concerns for startups and
entrepreneurs talk about temporary visas
and those are things they're going to be
relevant to you once you graduate those
are h-1b s and the T ends and and other
non-immigrant visas that will allow you
to start working once your opt expires
and we'll also talk a little bit about
the interplay between your f1 opt and
changing status to a longer term work
authorized that it's like the h-1b and
then we'll spend very very little time
talking about green cards because that's
probably not something that's that
relevant to you right now but just to
give you a brief overview so you know
what that's about and what options are
available to people like you who are
starting up companies in the United
States and then finally just a minute or
two on proposed legislation to help
entrepreneurs and startups you might
have heard of the the so called start a
visa act that was last year that
unfortunately I can go anywhere but
we'll talk a little bit about that and
what might be on the horizon for
proposed legislation in the future okay
so just gonna go through some basic
terminology so you understand this and
not only one we go through the rest of
the presentation but when you're talking
to potential employers or the you know
Foreign Studies office here you know
what this all means a non-immigrant is
someone who's a foreign national coming
to United States for temporary purpose
so if you're all in f1 student status
you're a non-immigrant you're coming
here temporarily for the purposes of
going to Stanford and learning an
immigrant is someone that's coming to
the United States for permanent purposes
so that's someone who's going planning
on living here permanently and
traditionally the non immigrants and the
immigrants were two very separate things
and and you couldn't be a non-immigrant
with the intention of becoming an
immigrant of living here permanently so
you had to show and many of you might
have had to show this when you applied
for your f1 your intention to go back to
your home country you know proof that
you have ties in your home country that
you know your your family is going to be
missing you so that that's traditionally
how it works and it still works for most
visa classification it works that way
for the f1 however
some non-immigrant visa classifications
are what we call dual and ten
classifications and those include the
h-1b and l1 and what that means is is
that you can come on an f1 you still
when you apply for the f1 you have to
show your intention of coming here
temporarily but once you're here you can
change to h-1b and l1 status and once
you're in h-1b no 1 status you're it's
fine for your intention to be to live
here permanently so you don't face those
restrictions when you go to apply for a
visa an h-1b visa they're not going to
say oh are you planning on going home to
to Germany they don't care
with the h1 or the l1 so it's a good
classification to be in yes the dual
intent has been you know de-facto rule
for a very long time before I started
practicing negation law it was actually
added to the the regulations and the
statute I believe in 2000 or 1999 or
2000 so it's been around for a long time
but again that only applies to h-1b and
l1 and to a lesser extent II 1 e 2 and
o1 which your classifications will touch
on finally lawful permanent resident
green card holder this is someone who's
been granted permanent residency they're
living here permanently
they they have no restrictions on where
they work what they do they can do
whatever they want so long as it's legal
okay so non-immigrant visa and this is
an important distinction between a
non-immigrant visa on arrival departure
record most of you unless you're from
Canada are going to have an f1 visa with
your picture on it in your passport
that's a non-immigrant visa is issued by
the consular service abroad either a
consulate or embassy abroad that allows
you to enter the country
the arrival/departure record is what
Customs and Border Protection gives you
at the port of entry when you enter the
country a little white piece of paper
and it has a handwritten expiration date
sometimes this computer-generated once
you're here what's relevant is the
arrival departure record that's what
determines how long you can stay here
for F one's that period is D /s they
don't have an expiration date which
means that as long as you're a student
as long as you're enrolled in school and
you have an i-20 that covers your period
of studies you're in valid status but
it's important to know
these because sometimes people will say
oh my non-immigrant my visa is expiring
the the thing in their passport with a
picture on it that doesn't matter once
you're here maybe it's issued for two
months once you're here what controls
your period of authorized stay is the
i-94 so when you switch to h-1b or l1 or
whatever you switch to that's going to
have an expiration date on it and that
expiration date is very important if you
stay beyond that then you can you know
find yourself in all sorts of trouble
but as an f-1 student it's just the d /
s which means that that's you can you
can stay here so long as you're you're
you know enrolled in school and your
i-20 covers your studies if you have a
question or okay d s yes d / yes yeah we
can talk about that later maybe in the
after session are there many people here
on a j-1
okay yeah I mean it's very similar it's
the D / s and you know duration of
status once you enter the country yeah
it's not that's a good way to put it
yeah I mean it's a it's complicated but
the the you know I bring this up mainly
because when you do switch to a work
authorized status you're gonna have an
expiration date and it's very important
to keep an eye on that because if you
overstay that then it's then it's a
problem but yeah as an f-1 or a j1 and
you have the duration of status yeah if
you stay beyond the i-20 which is issued
for the f1 or the IEP 66 which is issued
for the the the the or the ds-2019 which
is issued for the j1 that's also an
issue but it's not as big of an issue
next next thing I want to mention is
petition based non-immigrant
classification and what that is is
usually work authorized classifications
which require an employer usually an
employer to file a petition with the
Immigration Service get that petitioner
before you can get that non-immigrant
status so you're most of you are in f1
status that's not a petition based
non-immigrant classification you get an
i' you get an i-20 from the school says
that yeah you're accepted here there
they're gonna have you go to school you
take that i-20 you apply for an f1 visa
at the consulate with a petition based
classification we have to go to the
Immigration Service in the United States
get their approval on a piece of paper
and then take that and get the visa and
and and and that's important because the
Immigration Service is not always the
easiest government agency to deal with
and I'm going to be careful what I say
because I know I'm being videotaped but
it's much different when you're dealing
with Stanford and they're issuing i-20
and they're you going to the consulate
abroad and they just say oh you're going
to Stanford that's great there you go so
that those are just some basic concepts
the next thing that we're gonna talk
about our initial concerns for startups
and and this is really geared to those
of you who are thinking about starting
up a company when you graduate you're on
f1 opt status or j1 status and you want
to start up a company here as one of the
founders or one of the initial employees
even or maybe joining a startup
maybe there's a start-up that's already
joined that has five or six employees
and you're thinking about joining that
company as opposed to Google these are
important considerations the USCIS the
Immigration Service has a fraud profile
that targets smaller and newly formed
companies and this is not this is this
is actually we've seen the fraud profile
so it's not something it's not a
conspiracy theory they've they
accidentally leaked it it's not a
WikiLeaks yet but it was released to
someone on to a lawyer inadvertently so
we've all seen a copy of it and these
are some of the things that matter to
the USCIS size matters must have
commercially zoned premise a commercial
lease is best so you want to start up a
company out of your apartment you want
to get an h-1b that's going to be a
problem the the whole idea of Silicon
Valley and and you know garage startups
doesn't work if you're on an f1 and
you're switching to an h-1b must have
money to pay salaries you know there's
there's prevailing wage requirements
with the h-1b which we'll talk about and
even for other not in classifications
they want to see that you got money in
the bank that's gonna pay the salary
that's indicated on the h-1b petition so
sometimes people come to me say we have
50,000 we want to start a company and
and my salaries gonna be a hundred
thousand it's hard to do that they're
gonna ask how we're gonna get the rest
of the money to pay the salary must have
working dedicated phone number this is
less of a concern we haven't seen it as
much but you know sometimes people they
have their cell phone and you know they
they want us to put that on the petition
and the USCS is gonna call in or say hey
you know I mean they want to hear
someone's this is Acme Inc or whatever
must comply with all local state and
federal ordinances obviously and this
sometimes causes confusion you start up
a company here in Palo Alto
it doesn't require a business license in
Palo Alto but they're gonna ask for that
anyway these are the kinds of things
that they're looking for if you have
existing employees they're gonna want to
see payroll records so maybe you're
gonna say okay we got three people
working for us maybe they're all working
for equity but if you don't have the
payroll records you can't really say
that you got three employees they're
gonna want to see that they're you know
they're they're regular paid employees
with taxes withheld and it's also
helpful to have insurance receipts for
services equipment etc basically what
they're looking for is a lot of
documentation to show that it's an
actual business in sort of the you know
the the view that the u.s. CI sees
businesses they don't see them as
startups working out of garages they see
them as big organizations most of the
petitions they see are from companies
like IBM and Google so you know they
want to see all these little indicators
sure so long as it's legal it's fine
so yeah VC funding is obviously is the
way that I mean usually when we're doing
a start-up for an h-1b there's no
revenue so you know we have to put on
the form we say you know 20 million
hopefully an NBC funding usually it's
somewhat less than that but that's the
idea
we'll talk it well we can address that
question afterwards that's a little bit
more tricky and complicated the newness
of the company matters to us is as well
is generally difficult for newly formed
companies to sponsor employees for
petition based work authorization
because they don't have quarterly wage
statements again payroll records tax
returns proven revenue a track record of
doing business public records and
information on the web one of the things
that the USCIS has started doing
recently is they've started using dun &
bradstreet
which is a company that you might have
heard of that tracks data about
companies to verify the existence of
companies which is really a bad idea
because dun & bradstreet frankly is not
always up to date in fact I went to a
stakeholders meeting in DC talking about
this new pilot program of using dun &
bradstreet data and the dun & bradstreet
data people that were there said you
know yeah the data is usually up-to-date
and I had my paralegal look up our data
and it was 3 or 4 years out of date so I
mean it's it's it's it's just another
thing that that indicates how difficult
it is for smaller companies the dun &
bradstreet data for Google is probably
pretty close to up-to-date it's not
going to be first startup company or
they might not even be in dun &
bradstreet
so in terms of what needs to be done
with this if you're starting up a
company you're probably gonna have to
take all these steps that you wouldn't
otherwise have to do go to dun &
bradstreet get your company data in
there you know start paying employees
rather than just have them on equity and
you know get a commercial lease for
office space stealth companies are
problematic cuz there's no information
on the internet a lot of times the
startup company as you know is gonna be
in stealth mode they don't want to tell
people what they're doing if we try and
file an h-1b in that situation it can be
difficult particularly if the company
doesn't want to release anything to the
to the Immigration Service there's
nothing on the website nothing to verify
what they're doing so the way that we
generally handle that is we have an
explanation of this is a stealth company
and we provide some documentation which
we say to treat
potentially with the Immigration Service
describing what the company is going to
do and owner employee immigration
sponsorship very difficult because of
USCIS is new narrow interpretation of
employment which essentially states that
sponsored employees must be controlled
by others so you want to start a company
you're going to be a co-founder let's
say you're going to own 60% of the
company it's going to be very difficult
to do an h-1b for that and other
classifications as well but particularly
h-1b because they're going to say
there's no employer employee
relationship because you the employer
and you the employee are one in the same
so that's the position that they take
right now and that makes it very
difficult and really there's nothing you
can do about that except you know try
and do something where you don't have a
majority ownership know if you if you're
the only founder it depends I mean
there's other visa classifications right
now we're sort of talking about some of
the you know the h-1b the petition based
visa processes but there there might be
other options that we'll talk about here
and we'll it but usually for most people
h-1b is the only way that they have but
depending on your nationality and
depending on how much money you're
putting into it there's other options so
now we're going to talk about some of
the common non-immigrant visa
classifications for for people like you
first of all one that you're very
familiar with f1 as you know when you
graduate you should get a year of
optional practical training some of you
might be working pursuant to curricular
practical training right now which
allows you to work while you're going to
school the f1 12 months the opt the f1
opt gives you 12 months once you
graduate basically you can work wherever
you want so long as you're getting paid
and it's above minimum wage I guess so
that that is a I mean that works
actually very well for people that want
to start a company because you have that
first year where really no one's looking
over your shoulder the USCIS is not
saying well is that really work the only
people that you have to deal with is the
Stanford Foreign Studies office and as I
understand they're pretty
you know understanding in this and then
that they're fine with students using
their Opie to start a company the next
one is the h-1b workers and specialty
occupations and that's sort of the
standard work visa and we'll talk more
about that but that's that's for anybody
that's that's working in the United
States for an employer and what's called
a specialty occupation a position a
position that requires a specific degree
in a specific field and sort of the
quintessential h-1b Zoar engineers
you know lawyers those type of positions
where it's easy to identify that you
have to have a specific degree in a
specific field the the o1 alien of
extraordinary ability that's for people
that have risen to the very top of their
field we often do that for people that
are PhDs or startup founders that have
you know started other companies raised
lots of money made lots of money those
type of things it's very high standard
to meet though and the e2 treaty
investors we'll talk more about that as
well this is something that might work
for some some of you most countries we
have treaties with that allow for
investors
I shouldn't say most countries but you
know most people are covered by treaties
with countries that we have that allow
people from from these countries to come
here start a business start an
investment in an enterprise and get a
work visa to manage that business to run
that business now there are some catches
too that we'll talk about that but but
it is an option that that could be
looked at in all cases and it's
something that we've done for people
that have graduated from the business
school in the past here be one business
visitor that is that is a status that
allows people to come here for purposes
of business that doesn't involve work
but you can use that to start a company
to start a company or look into starting
a company but you can't
once the company's up and running you
can't really work in b1 status and then
there's some other visa classifications
that tiens for Canada I don't know I'm
sorry
yes yeah sorry just a little
introduction so other visa
classifications the TN
which are available to Canadians and
Mexicans which is a work visa
classification the h-1b ones which are
available to Singaporeans and Chileans I
don't know if anyways from Singapore
Chile here and the e threes
which are available to Australian
citizens so we'll just touch on those
very briefly so if you're not from
Canada Mexico Chile Singapore Australia
then you know that you have a harder
time and thinking about the different
options that are available we have to
ask what which classification is best
and these are questions that I always
ask clients with startups to determine
that when does employees opt if
applicable expire what country is the
employee from how far along is the
company in setting up how much capital
has to start appraised and from what
source from what source is very
important so is the amount but from what
source is very important if it comes
from a VC in the United States it will
preclude out possibly other options for
investor visas how much ownership
interest will the employee have in the
company and as I mentioned that's a
relevant concern because it can be
difficult to get a work visa where the
employee that's being sponsored is also
a majority owner on the other hand it
will open up other options potentially
for some people what is the nature of
the business and how big will the
operation be so as you know I just
mentioned these is sort of inter
deduction as we go through the different
in more detail to the different visa
classifications you'll understand why
these questions are relevant F one
practical training as I mentioned is
issues for startups requires employment
so must get paid so you can't just hang
out on your opt unfortunately you got to
get money from somewhere and I as I
understand it most schools and I think
Stanford as well they're pretty flexible
with that they're not you know you don't
have to get paid a whole bunch of money
but you do need to get paid somehow
there's two types of practical training
again the optional practical training
generally granted for up to 12 months
it's usually post
completion you can get opt prior to
graduating but usually people wait they
save it till they graduate and they take
their full 12 months then must notify
the school of the employer that's very
important that's sort of a new rule a
couple years ago so when you start
working somewhere you got to go back to
Stanford say hey I'm working here and
let them know you can't have any more
than 90 days of unemployment so you can
not work for a little bit of time but if
you exceed that 90 days then you're in
violation of status and also important
is it has to be related to your degree
program so if you're using your opt to
work as a waiter it might be difficult
case to make that it's related to your
MBA program curricular practical
training is essentially an internship
while you're going to school so people
get curricular practical training to you
know to work at companies like you know
IBM or Google or whatever you can also
use it with a start-up but it must be
part of the curriculum and it has to be
specifically approved by the Foreign
Studies office here so you can't they
need to look at what you're doing and
they might I'm sure they have some forms
that you need to fill out and they need
to approve it before you can do it 90
days total
I don't think there's anything new but
I'll that's something there there are
some there are some specific things
about self-employment in the in the
regulations but we can talk about talk
about that but yeah opt you can use to I
mean self-employment is is a you know
you can work as an independent
contractor for example in opt you get
like a 1099 but you do have to be
receiving compensation so I guess it
depends on what you mean by
self-employment if you're just you know
building a house and not getting paid
for it that would yes yeah that's fine
that's fine you can do it but again you
you can't you can't just be
self-employed and not making money
because that's essentially not doing
anything right or just doing a hobby the
way it works is is if you use a full
year of CPT then you're ineligible for
opt but conceivably you can do like six
months of CPT and then still have your
one year of opt does that make sense
okay let's talk about the h-1b workers
and specialty occupations again this is
the most common work visa it's for
workers in positions that would normally
require at least a bachelor's degree in
a specific field and again engineers and
lawyers are sort of the quintessential
ones does not require temporary intent
as I mentioned there's a six year
maximum time limit so people in h-1b
status can only get six years total
however if you start the green card
process within enough time usually
that's
before the the end of your fifth year as
an h-1b then you can extend your h-1b
indefinitely while that green card
process is is going and that's very
important for some people from certain
countries because there's huge backlogs
for green cards so if you're from India
or China the backlog could be as long as
eight or nine years and if you only get
six years as an h-1b then obviously
that's gonna be a problem so they
changed the law in 2000 that now allows
you to extend that h-1b indefinitely
while you're waiting for your green card
so long as you start the green card
process soon enough and that's that's
something that's unique to the h-1b
another important feature the h-1b is
that you can port from one employer to
another before the petitions approve so
you're working at one company you want
to work at another company once the new
company files the h-1b petition you can
start working for the new company and
that's that's that's unique to the h-1b
as well no it doesn't unfortunately
question was in case whether the h-1b
six-year limit is reset by going to f1
status it is not while you're an f1
status you don't use that six years so
you still have the balance of what you
had before however the only way that you
can reset it is being physically out of
the United States for one year
continuous year yeah you still have the
balance I think we should save that for
after because that's kind of a
complicated and I'd rather my answer not
be on film
yeah yeah yeah every time you file a new
h-1b petition with a new employer it's
all the same fees all the same paperwork
there are some advantages like the
portability so you can port from one
employer to the other you don't have to
wait for it to be approved but it's the
same paperwork so sometimes people say
oh I'm it's just an h-1b transfer
there's no real such thing as an h-1b
transfer it's always a new petition the
government fees well it depends on the
attorneys fees and the government well
it also depends on the size of the
company and whether you want premium
processing and there's a lot of things
but generally it's going to be for most
four to five thousand dollars yeah well
that's why we they start up depending on
the position and depending on how big
the company is your immigration attorney
will hopefully tell you that let's wait
till it's approved rather than have him
quit because if it does get denied then
he's he's a ezel he's in a hard
situation so I always tell me if I think
it's clearly going to be approved then
I'll say yeah go ahead and have them
change but if it's a it's one of those
cases that I think the USCIS might give
us a hard time on it so well you know we
filed premium processing it's only going
to take a couple weeks anyway so let's
just wait till then so challenges for
startups and entrepreneurs in the h-1b
again the fraud profile which is
specifically for the h-1b they're
looking at the size of the company and
and when when the USCIS is adjudicating
small company h-1bs
they interpret specialty occupation much
more narrowly than they do for large
companies and there are certain kinds of
positions and unfortunately business
positions which they're going to be
they're going to scrutinize very very
closely so if you have a startup company
with five or six people and let's say
it's got a million dollars in VC fun
and you're hiring a software engineer
with a degree in computer science to
work for you yeah probably I can have a
problem with that but if you're hiring a
business systems analyst or you know a
director of marketing much more likely
that you're gonna have a problem with
that it's not to say you can't do it and
you know the Immigration Service has
gotten a little better over the last
year but it is a more problem out of
case so that's one of those cases if it
were a portability case you might say
let's just wait for it to be approved
just to play it safe well they look at
both but usually the degrees not the
problem I mean you know they're they're
you know someone has a degree in
engineering and they have a an MBA
they're not gonna say well is that
really an MBA I mean I heard Stanford's
a good school but they're really looking
at does the position and the things that
they look at is like do you really
you've got five people why do you need a
director of marketing so they sort of
impose their business judgment in the
you know process of adjudicating your
h-1b they that that's a complicated
question there's there's a certain
portion of the government filing fees
that the employee cannot pay by law
however there are reasons that the
employee should not pay other portions
of it depending on how much the person
is making relative to other employees of
the company and I know that's not a very
clear answer but just in the interest of
time we can take that up in the after
session if you'd like
yeah there is it there is an annual cap
for h1 B's and I think we get to that
next slide so I'll just wait to hole
talk about that okay so I'm just all
right absolutely
well I mean you can you know one one one
one tactic or strategy not sure which is
to you know try to file an h-1b if it's
you know you get to give yourself
multiple bites at the Apple so sometimes
people do that the company's kind of
small now why don't we try it now I mean
it costs money obviously and you're
gonna lose all that money if it gets
denied and then if it doesn't work out
you still have your opt I mean there's
some there's some issues with that
there's some logistical issues with that
but sometimes that makes sense because
one of the things and we'll talk about
with is this with a cap is that the
economy starts to really start moving
again it might be very difficult to get
an h-1b now I think everybody here is
graduating MBA so you get a special set
aside your chances of getting one are
better again I'm sort of jumping the gun
and talking about the cap but you know
what happened in 2007 is that even
people with masters only 90 percent of
them got h-1b she had to file on one day
so if you were an unlucky one in 10 your
case was was unlucky and you didn't get
picked in the lottery and and so
sometimes it makes sense to say okay I
got the year of opt but let's try filing
now just in case the economy is gonna
get really really good next year and I'm
not gonna have a chance in the lottery
again I'm sorry I'm sort of jumping the
gun I'm talking about the cap so the the
h-1b is problematic as I mentioned for
executives and managers because they're
not traditionally specialty occupations
again it doesn't mean that you can't
make it happen but it's more difficult
and it's in the risk of a denial or
higher what we tend to do is is if we're
doing someone with a master's degree an
MBA and it's sort of a technical
position and they have an undergraduate
technical degree will sort of pin the
position on that because that's more of
a clear specialty occupation
I mean if you get promoted to CEO then
we have file an amendment of your h-1b
is normally what we would do and if we
were to do that CEO we would still try
and pin it on your your technical
background so this isn't just a CEO like
the CEO of you know u-haul it requires
someone with a technical background I
don't know why you call came to my mind
and again as we mentioned it's
increasingly difficult where the
sponsored h-1b employee has ownership
interest in the company if you have 25%
30% and we have all the indices of an
employment relationship and employment
agreement offer a letter all that stuff
pay stubs it's not likely going to be a
problem but if you own 50% or more than
it could be a problem
and finally the downsides of the h-1b
it's relatively expensive in terms of
government filing fees as I mentioned
it's between usually between four and
five thousand dollars with premium
processing depending on the size of the
company more downsides annual cap
subject to annual cap of 65,000 and of
these 6700 are reserved for Chileans and
Singaporeans remember I said they have
that special treaty status with
Singapore and Chile well they took those
visa numbers in that treaty out of the
general pot and reserved it for them and
you know being that Singapore is a small
country and there's not a lot of people
from Chile coming here they don't use
that whole 6700 so what happens is is
that that unused portion gets put in the
cap for the next year and that's where
we're at right now this year so last
year I think there was only you know a
few hundred h-1b ones for Chile and
Singapore and they just added those to
the or met you know indicated how many
of those are left over for this year so
we've actually already reached the
normal cap for fiscal year 2011 which is
6500 - 6700 but because most of that
6700 is left over from last year gets
added to the pot so we've still have
about three or four thousand left for
this year
no it's fiscal year starts October 1st
2011 started October 1st 2010 so you
know if you look at if you look at the
the numbers that were released a couple
weeks ago and it shows that you know
there's 61 thousand regular h-1bs that
have been used up so know the caps been
reached but it's not because we had
these leftovers from Chile and Singapore
last year now for all of you that are
graduating with an MBA there's twenty
thousand in addition to that that are
set aside for people with master's
degree from US schools that cap for this
fiscal year has already been reached
okay that doesn't mean you can't get an
h-1b because we haven't reached the
regular cap it's just that special
set-aside has been reached and what
happens when there's a huge demand for
h-1b s like there was in 2007 the
regular h-1bs would run out first so it
really meant something to have those
additional 20,000 for master's degree
holders but what we're seeing is there's
a lot more people graduating with
master's so it's quite possible that the
master's cap and the H regular h-1b cap
when the economy gets good will run out
around the same time it depends if you
had held h-1b status in last six years
and you still have time left you haven't
used up your whole six years yeah that's
correct the question was if you've had
an h-1b in the past you know you went
back to school to get an MBA can you
reactivate that h-1b without being
subject to the cap and the answer is yes
if it meets those conditions I'm sorry
Swiss employers know it doesn't no it
doesn't the the way that cap works is if
you've been counted against the cap once
in the last six years you're not subject
to the cap okay that's just a gloss but
there's a little bit more complicated in
that but so essentially what I tell
people is if you've had if you've held
h-1b status in the past chances are
you're not subject to their annual quota
another downside of the h-1b there's a
lot of employer restrictions on it
unlike most other visa classifications
the employer has to pay the prevailing
wage and they have to keep very detailed
records on you know payroll and and
working conditions in compliance with
the Department of Labor regulations so
for startups that's particularly
difficult because you don't you probably
have not very much administrative
support everybody's wearing multiple
hats and then you you have to read this
long instruction book that we send
people that explains how to do all this
stuff obviously for a bigger company
they have a whole department and
probably a person specifically doing
that and that's all they do but that is
a downside and one of the and part of
the reasons that that's difficult for
startups is that when you start a
company let's say you're gonna be the
CEO and you want to take a small salary
and just you know take equity for most
of your compensation can't do that with
the h-1b there's a prevailing wage
requirement you have to be paid what the
Department of Labor says CEO should be
making in the area of intended
employment and that figure is very high
so when doing an h-1b for a startup
there has to be some sort of flexibility
in what your role is going to be at the
company if you if you file an h-1b for a
CEO you know $150,000 and that they're
not going to consider equity or bonuses
it has to be salary paid at least once a
month
finally no spousal work authorization
for h-1b some other visa classifications
that we'll talk about
there is your spouse can work in
basically open market employment while
you're here doesn't apply to h-1b
you know I'm gonna try and just get
things moving because I think we're
running a little short on time
oh one aliens of extraordinary ability
again this is for people that are really
at the top of their fields so someone
who's a you know documented achievements
and in business startups or technology
we often duo ones for them people with
PhDs it's it's it's a it's usually a
pretty good choice usually if the h-1b
is available as an option we'll start
there because even though the filing
fees are less for the o1 it's a lot of
preparation it's a lot of work and and
you know the person really has to be
able to show a lot of documents
demonstrating their extraordinary
abilities so I'm just going to sort of
skip through that because I think that's
a less important than some of these
other things the next thing I want to
talk about is the e2 treaty investor and
this applies to people from a lot of
countries we have treaties with
countries you know many countries most
countries in in Western Europe many
countries in Asia which allow for people
to come to the United States to start a
business and get Visa Classic pursuant
to that business and running that
business but there are some important
restrictions that are relevant to people
like you who are going to be starting up
a company and possibly seeking VC
funding first of all the enterprise has
to be at least fifty percent owned and
controlled by Nationals of the treaty
country so if you're coming here and
you're going to start a company and
you're not going to own at least fifty
percent of it or you're not gonna have
other people from your you know country
owning 50 percent of it then the e2 is
not going to work and that's often the
case because you might be co-founding
with some US people or you might be
receiving so much VC funding that you're
not going to have at least 50 percent
ownership so that's an important
restriction it's it's available to
people in managerial executive or
specialized positions so if you're
running the business an executive or
manager you can qualify if you're an
engineer or sort of a highly specialized
position at the company you can also
qualify so it's not only the investors
that couldn't can use the e to you know
let's say you start a company and you do
any you know you do you your own e2
the company and then you want to hire
someone from let's say it's uh you know
Germany and you decide you want to hire
some guy that you know is a great
engineer he's not going to own any of
the company he's not going to manage it
but he's a great engineer you can hire
that person pursuant to the e2
classification and it's a lot less it's
going to ultimately be less expensive
and less restrictive than the h-1b it's
also based on a substantial investment
the United States so you know let's say
you come here you're starting a company
you're gonna own 50% or maybe more but
all that all the cash is coming from a
VC in the United States that's gonna be
a problem you have to show that there's
a substantial amount of money coming
from the the investors of the treaty
country and it doesn't necessarily have
to be money can be equipment
theoretically it could be intellectual
property but that's very very difficult
because you have to provide a you know
objective valuation of it
some of the benefits it allows us allows
spouse work authorization so if you're
coming on a knee to your husband or wife
can can work anywhere he or she wants
while you're on the e to very few
employer restrictions does not require
and this is this is probably one of the
best benefits does not require a
petition with the USCIS ahead of time so
again one of the issues with the h-1b
and other petition based work authorized
classifications is we have to deal with
the Immigration Service and they tend to
be a little less open-minded frankly
that the consular service is what
adjudicates most eetu applications and
they their training is more to
facilitate international trade and you
know help realize the the goal of these
treaties which is to allow people from
the US to go to that country and people
from that country to come here to invest
so the e2 I think is much more the the
adjudication of the e2 is much more
reasonable again the downside
substantial investment u.s. so
representative office or sales office
don't qualify processing generally takes
much longer than other classifications
depending on the country
in Canada they can take several months
in you know Chile it might only take a
couple weeks no you need to I mean
there's a lot of there's a lot of
documentation that you have to show with
you too much more so than even the h-1b
it just means that you don't have to
file a petition with the Immigration
Service prior to getting classification
you apply directly at the consulate or
embassy abroad it's a substantial
investment that depends on the nature of
the enterprise so if you're starting a
hotdog stand the substantial investment
is going to be a lot less than a factory
the minute my rule of thumb the absolute
minimum is a hundred thousand dollars
we won't there's nothing in the
regulations it says but we won't do any
- unless there's a hundred thousand
dollars and that's you know if someone
says that they're gonna open a you know
semiconductor fab and they say their
investments a hundred thousand obviously
that's not gonna work it just really
depends on the enterprise and you know
when doing the e2 we need a business
plan it all has to make sense in terms
of the business plan you know if you
have this amount of investment is that
gonna work for what you're planning on
doing so I'm gonna just sort of try and
go through this the B one visitor status
again does not allow work authorization
but is a status that you can use to
explore starting a business and actually
start a business so you can come on a B
one business visitor or the Visa Waiver
if you qualify if you're from a Visa
Waiver country and use that to you know
talk to potential investors look for
office space even hire people but once
the business is up and running you need
to switch to l1 or e2 status if you if
if the company is qualified yeah I mean
it's yeah I mean basically when you're
actually started receiving money from
clients or I would say even before that
getting paid if you're you know
definitely if you're getting paid by the
company here you definitely need to be
in work authorized status but even if
you're not getting paid and the
companies starting to generate revenue
you
we should be in work authorized status
there's nothing that really delineates
that in the statute of the regulations
but the the B one depends on if you come
in a Visa Waiver so if you're from a
Visa Waiver country it's 90 days at a
time and then you have to leave and then
you can come back if your if you
actually apply for a b-1 visa
it will only be granted for up to six
months at a time and oftentimes they'll
grant it for much less depending on what
your purposes are so if you say I'm
going to a seminar in Las Vegas for you
know two weeks and they're only gonna
grant for two weeks possibly so it
really just depends well again we go
back to the the you know some of the
initial concepts here the the visa the
expiration date on the visa stamp is
there relevant once you enter the
country what's relevant is the i-94 that
determines how long you can stay so you
have a b-1 visa stamp that's valid for
ten years but your i-94 but you didn't
enter on to be one right oh but yeah if
you were to and you don't to be going to
school on a b-1 the the you know when
you come in on the b-1 they'll grant it
for usually six months not allowed to
receive salary or compensation from us
source offer your services for hire so
that's another thing that comes up you
know you start a company and you're
starting to you know do stuff for other
companies and you really can't do that
or other activities involving local
employment okay just real briefly TNS if
you're Canadian
that's a classification that might work
it allows you to skip the Immigration
Service downsides with that very limited
class occupational classifications
there's no executive or you know regular
management type of position under the TN
regulations it's for very specific
positions like engineer accountant
lawyers etc etc so oftentimes it doesn't
really work for people like you that are
starting up a company even if you are
Canadian or Mexican h-1b one again we
touched on this it's very much like the
h-1b but it's said there's a set aside
for Chile and Singapore the advantages
of it if you qualify
our that first of all it doesn't go
through the OCS applied directly at the
consular embassy filing fees are much
much less expensive III again that's
very that is also very much like the
h-1b in terms of what the requirements
are but it's not it's not petition based
if you're Australian you can apply
directly at the consulate or embassy in
Australia there's a separate quota it's
not taken out of the regular h-1b cap of
10,000 the next classification we'll
talk about and and I'm going to keep
this brief as well because I don't think
it's a little too to many of you is the
l-1b multinational l-1a and l-1b
multinational manager let's say you have
a company that you started or you know
you work for abroad and you've worked
there for at least a year and when you
graduate from Stanford after your
two-year program you want to go back and
start a company here in the United
States with that company a subsidiary
essentially the l1 classification
theoretically should allow you to do
that if you've worked at a company
abroad for one year in the last three
years of course would be cutting it very
tight you're going to school for two
years you can work for a subsidiary
parent or affiliate of that foreign
company in l1 status so you know just to
go back to that example you you have a
company of maybe ten people in Belgium
and you know you're coming here for your
MBA when you graduate you're gonna start
up a subsidiary of that company in
Belgium here in Palo Alto that makes
chocolate or something so that should
seem like a good option the problem is
is that even more so than the h-1b the
USCIS hates el ones for small companies
the chances of a denial for a small
company an l1 are extremely high so we
almost never do this for startups we do
it where there's no other option or we
know that we have a fallback so let's
give it a let's give it a shot if it
doesn't work because there's some
advantages to the l1 if you get it
compared to the e2 it doesn't work we'll
do an 8 we'll do an e2 that might be a
situation where we do the l1 but it's
and I just mention it so you might hear
about it so well why don't we do that
if you
that situation it's just it's very very
difficult you can't be unless it's
related unless it meets those
qualifications so if you're working for
let's say a subsidiary of the Belgian
chocolate company here and then you want
to switch and work at Google it's not
going to work because there's no
relationship between Google and the
Belgian company okay just going to talk
a little bit more about the cap gap
issue and that is the situation where
all of you might find yourself in where
you have your one year of opt and then
you need to switch to h-1b because of
the limited filing season for h-1b s
oftentimes what happens is it when your
opt expires there's no H one B's left
right now we're looking at h-1bs for
fiscal year 2011 being reached in the
next couple weeks maybe maybe a month or
so so if you're if you don't already
have an h-1b approved and you have your
opt once your opt expires then you might
be in a bad situation depending on you
know when it expires the regulations now
allow for what are called cap gap
provisions this means that if you if
you're if you file an h-1b for the next
fiscal year so that'd be fiscal year
2012 before your opt expires then your
opt work authorization will be extended
till the beginning of the next fiscal
year so where this might come into play
is let's say in you know let's say you
you're graduating in the fall of excuse
me the spring of this year your opt is
going to take you tell June of 2012 that
it's 12 months so it'll take you you
know from the time you graduate till
until June 2012 you file an h-1b as soon
as that you're likely gonna be able to
file an h-1b is April 1st 2012 for the
next fiscal year the problem is that
your ear before that fiscal year starts
on October 1st your opt will have
expired
this
cap gap provision means that you can
extend your h-1b until it till until the
beginning of the fiscal year does that
sort of make sense or is that just clear
as mud
all right good yeah that applies to you
the other thing is stem extension which
is mentioned here wouldn't apply to an
MBA student if you're graduating in a
stem field science technology
engineering or mathematics you can
actually extend your opt for 17 months
so long as the employer that you're
working for is enrolled in e-verify
which I won't go into so and that's
regardless of whether an h-1b is filed
the cap gap thing which is applicable to
you only applies if you file an h-1b
within the you know requisite time
period so that's just a very you know
short summary of that but if you have
questions about it feel free to contact
me green cards again I don't think this
is too relevant to you now because you
know right now you're probably just
thinking about getting a getting a work
visa once you graduate but just to just
to give a broad overview of some of the
what might be relevant classifications
and considerations one issue for
startups is financial resources when you
whenever you do an employer sponsored
green card case you have to be able to
show the companies the ability to pay
the salary so if you're if you're saying
that you're gonna make a hundred
thousand dollars they're gonna want to
show want to see proof that you can do
that with either tax returns financial
statements or payable records and
obviously that's difficult for startups
immigrant intent that might come into
play some people want to start the green
card process with a start-up or is a you
know some other classification while
they're an f1 opt status that's
difficult because the f1 opt is a strict
non-immigrant status and you could face
problems traveling and re-entering the
country if you're starting the green
card process before embarking on the
green card process you should talk to a
tax advisor there are implications in
terms of taxes and now just real briefly
means a sponsorship there's there's a
most people who are employer sponsored
as green card holders do so through her
labor certification
and that's a process where the employer
tests the US labor market to determine
whether there's any qualified US workers
who want the job and of course the
intention here is to make sure that no
US workers are being displaced to
protect US workers what that means for
startups is that it's difficult because
as a start-up if you're a founder or
co-founder you're probably going to have
some ownership interest in the company
and if you have an ownership interest in
the company and it's what's considered a
closely held company which a lot of
startups are the Department of Labor is
going to want you to disclose that when
you file the perm application and it's
going to be very very difficult to get
that approved so that's that's a very
important consideration because the
other means of green-card sponsorship
are very difficult when the company gets
to a certain level and it gets diluted
with venture capital we might be at the
point where we could say well it's not
closely held anymore but while it's
closely held it's it's III don't even I
wouldn't even want to file a perm
application for someone that owns 5% or
so of the company eb1 alien or Eastern
your ability this is very similar to the
o1 except the standard of review is much
higher so this is for people at a very
top of their field this might be you
know an executive who's done well and
made lots of money with previous
companies it's also done for actors and
performers and musicians and and and and
other things but you know that's a hard
standard to meet particularly in the
business field much easier for someone
who's got you know PhD or they've they
have a Nobel Prize or something like
that you have a Nobel Prize and you know
by all means let me know multinational
managers and executives this is very
similar to the l1 the l1 classification
that we just briefly touched on so if
you have a company abroad that you know
you're coming here and you're when you
graduate you're going to open a
subsidiary you're gonna join a
subsidiary you and you're going to work
in a managerial capacity or an executive
capacity at that company in the US and
you served in a managerial executive
capacity at the company abroad then you
should qualify as a multinational
manager executive but again for
small companies that's that's difficult
it's difficult to show that because you
might if you only have four or five
employees and you're saying that you're
the CEO the Immigration Service is going
to say the CEO of what you know they
want to see big companies with lots of
employees and finally the eb-5 investor
visa and you might have heard of this
but this is a green card visa
classification that allows for people to
get a green card if they're investing a
million dollars and in some cases half a
million dollars depending on if it's in
a targeted economic area to start a
business that creates at least ten jobs
and there's a two-year conditional
residency requirement so what you have
to do is you have to take the money
start a business you know start you know
buying stuff and get space and all that
and then you file a petition saying oh
yeah here's my business here's my
business plan I put in the money it's
legal I got it from legal means and then
they give you a two-year conditional
green card and at the end of that two
years you have to show that you in fact
did or are likely going to create the
ten jobs that you're required to and
that the business is still running now
important aspect of this it has to be
your money you can't you know use
someone else's money you can't use VC
funding it has to be your own money and
they're gonna trace it they're gonna go
back five years to make sure that that's
your money and you got it from a legal
means yes yes if you get your green card
through Google then you can then your
permanent resident you do whatever you
want or if you get your green card
through marriage it depends on your
background right now it's going very
quickly through perm labor certification
it also depends on if the perm is
audited some cases are audited in that
case it takes much longer it depends on
your it depends on your your academic
background it depends on your
nationality or actually not your
nationality excuse me the country that
you're born in and in some cases might
depend on the country your wife is born
in or your husband so there's a lot of
factors but it let's just to give you an
exam
someone that's working for Google or you
know some other company established
company they have a master's degree
they're in a position that requires a
master's degree and they're born in
Canada and Google starts the perm
process it might only take three or four
months to get the the the perm taken
care of
based on current processing times and
then the rest of the process maybe six
or nine months so you get the the best
case scenario is a green card in about a
year
worst case scenario you're born in India
you're in a position that only requires
a bachelor's degree that might be eight
or nine years usually most companies
most of my clients they wait a year they
want to see you working for a year
startups might have more flexibility
they want to attract the best talent
let's say we'll do it right away for you
but most companies they they have a yute
one year policy okay I know we're out of
time but I just just could have briefly
mentioned this and then we can move to
the other room the eb6 green card
category that was a proposed law it was
started last year you might have heard
about it
this would allow people like you to get
a green card by raising VC funding so
unlike the eb-5 which requires it be
your own money the eb6 would allow you
to raise VC funding and get a green card
that way
well the lot it can go anywhere so it's
you know it it unfortunately it failed
and Congress didn't pass it but it's
possible that'll be reintroduced in the
new session of Congress and and and it
might go somewhere
well you know I think that's a question
maybe we should wait because that's that
that's that requires more questions and
you know because it really depends I
can't just say oh you know a million
dollars because it also depends on what
you're doing people you're hiring if you
have office space and etc how much
you're going to own that kind of thing